wir fahren nach walnie ist bestürzend
das aus meiner Sicht ganz klar ein
Verbrechen also gegen die Menschheit das
ist nicht hinzunehmen das Putin also
hier
mit
verantwortlich ist das halte ich für
gegeben dann entweder werden die
Nervengifte nicht ausreichend geschützt
oder sie werden von ihm eingesetzt one
way or NASA wie man so sagt also ist das
tatsächlich hier Russland anzulasten und
von daher belastet das natürlich die das
Verhältnis zwischen Deutschland und
Russland zu recht schwer
ja also zunächst mal freut mich dass es
eine gesundheitlich wieder besser geht
aber diese Äußerungen da befinden wir
uns jetzt dann schon auf Stammtischen
Niveau ich finde auch Herrn wallny
sollte da seine Worte wohl abwägen mit
mir persönlich fehlt der letzte
schlüssige Beweis danach weiß wirklich
gerichtsfeste Nachweis dass Putin
persönlich diesen Angriff hätte
angeordnet ich meine mittlerweile ist es
ja sehr einfach man muss nur irgendwie
jemanden auf der Welt vergiften mit Navi
Schock und Putin war's das ist gerade so
wie wenn Mörder eine Visitenkarte am
Tatort hinterlässt für so dumm das sage
ich jetzt auch mal ganz offen ist meine
persönliche Meinung halte ich ein Putin
nicht also ich fand die
Einlassung von Gerhard Schröder zum
fallender weil nie auch schwierig muss
ganz ehrlich sagen dass das auch eines
Altkanzlers nicht würdig war ob da
Zahlungen fließen oder nicht dazu möchte
ich mich nicht äußern ich habe dazu
keine Kenntnisse kann das auch ehrlich
gesagt so weit nicht glauben aber
trotzdem die Rolle von Gerhard Schröder
ist schon zwei flaft aber insgesamt ist
dieser Vorfall natürlich zu verurteilen
insgesamt sind ist das ja nur ein Fall
von vielen die in der russischen mit der
Russischen Föderation in Zusammenhang
gebracht werden hier braucht es eine
internationale Antwort und hier ist die
Bundesregierung ja auch im Gespräch mit
vielen anderen Punkten hört jetzt die
ganze Welt hin natürlich weil er
vergiftet wurde in Russland aber auch
weil er der prominenteste Oppositionelle
ist und auch der prominenteste
investigativermittler in Russland
niemand hat so viel Korruption auf
höchster Staatsebene in Russland
aufgedeckt Wiener walni und nawalni hat
gestern sehr klar über Schröder
gesprochen und hat gesagt er weiß dass
Schröder in seiner eigenen Partei bei
der SPD mittlerweile auch kritisch
gesehen wird das haben wir gerade von
Herrn Karl Lauterbach gehört man kann
aber auch sehen an den Äußerungen von
Florian Post der zweite Abgeordnete der
gesprochen hat dass immer noch ein
völlig bizarres Russland Verständnis
vorherrscht er hat gesagt Herr Post hat
gesagt dass er nicht für so dumm hält
dass er seine Visitenkarte spricht das
novichog Gift einfach bei den Morden
hinterlässt ja ich halte Putin ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht für dumm ich glaube
das Problem liegt er bei westlichen
Abgeordneten die so gutgläubig sind und
tatsächlich sich einfach weigern die
Realität anzuerkennen wer konnte denn na
weil die in Russland vergiften mit einem
russischen militärischen
nervenkampfstoff ja und schauen wir uns
doch einfach mal die Ermittlungen an es
gibt keine Ermittlungen in Russland das
hat naval nie selbst auch gesagt heute
hat Außenminister lavrov echt vor
wenigen Minuten gesagt
dass der Nachweis das norwegschock
eingesetzt wurde ja nicht von der
Berliner Charité erbracht wurde sondern
vom bundeswehrlabor und dem könne man ja
natürlich nicht trauen man wissen nicht
welches Spiel Deutschland da spiele ja
also
das macht sehr klar wie die SPD da steht
da tut es ehrlich gesagt gut deutliche
Worte zu hören
wirklich vom
CSU-Abgeordneten Florian Hahn der sich
klar für Ermittlungen gegen Russland
ausgesprochen hat in deinen Augen müsste
die SPD sich klare abtrennen sowohl zu
Russland als auch zu Gerhard Schröder
und seiner Rolle die er jetzt spielt ja
also die SPD fährt seit vielen Jahren
eine etwas unklaren russlandkurs hat
viele Kreml Freunde bei sich in der
Partei das soll die SPD machen wie sie
will der falschschröder wird natürlich
einfach peinlich für die SPD also es
gibt wirklich kein Völkerrechtsbruch den
Russland begeht kein Angriffskrieg den
Putin veranstaltet den Herr Schröder
nicht sofort versucht schön zu reden und
jetzt das das ist wirklich einfach
peinlich das merkt auch die SPD-Spitze
dass das alexene valny in Russland
vergiftet wird auf Druck der
Bundesregierung nach Deutschland
ausgeflogen wird auch die so viel
Mitleid so viel Sympathie von der
deutschen Bevölkerung bekommt und dann
kommt Herr Schröder um die Ecke und
zweifelt alle Fakten an sagt es gebe gar
keines sei alles im Wesentlich eine
Spekulation versucht wieder den Kreml da
aus der Schusslinie zu bringen so was
kann sich
die ehemalige Volkspartei SPD eigentlich
nicht leisten vielen Dank Philipp
piatschow für diese Einschätzung
mehr Nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei Bild schau dir hier das nächste
Video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren